a polyprotic acid is an acid with more
than one proton that it can donate in
solution an example of a polyprotic acid
is the protonated form of the amino acid
alanine here's a dot structure showing
the protonated form of the amino acid
alanine and we can represent this as h2a
plus
let's say we're doing a titration with
the protonated form of alanine and we're
adding sodium hydroxide to an aqueous
solution of the protonated form the
protonated form of alanine has two
acidic protons so one acidic proton is
on the oxygen and the other acidic
proton is one of the protons bonded to
the nitrogen the proton bonded to the
oxygen is the more acidic of the two
therefore when we add some hydroxide
anions to the solution the hydroxide
anions will pick up this proton and form
water and convert the protonated form of
alanine into the overall neutral form of
alanine h a
let's say that we start out in our
titration with one mole of the
protonated form of alanine and then we
add in our hydroxide anions after we've
added in one mole of hydroxide anions
we've completely neutralized the
protonated form of alanine and h2a plus
is converted into h a
so one mole of h2a plus reacts with one
mole of hydroxide anions to form one
mole of h a
so now we have one mole of h a in
solution and if we continue to add
hydroxide anions hydroxide anions react
with h a
and take one of the acidic protons on
the nitrogen to form a minus a minus is
the conjugate base to h a it would take
another mole of hydroxide anions to
completely neutralize the h a and to
turn it into a minus so one mole of h a
reacts with one mole of hydroxide anions
to form one mole of a minus
so going back to the protonated form of
the amino acid alanine since the
protonated form has two acidic protons
we call this a diprotic acid so let me
go ahead and write in here diprotic and
because there are two acidic protons on
the protonated form of alanine there
will be two pka values which we can
figure out from the titration curve
next let's look at the titration curve
for the titration of our diprotic acid
with sodium hydroxide on the y-axis is
ph and on the x-axis is moles of
hydroxide anions added before we've
added any hydroxide anions so this point
right here on our titration curve we
have our diprotic acid present so h2a
plus
and since we started with one mole of
h2a plus it would take one mole of
hydroxide anions to completely
neutralize the h2a plus
so after one mole of hydroxide anions
has been added that brings us to
equivalence point one so we go to one
mole of hydroxide anions on the x-axis
and we go up to where that intersects
our titration curve and this point on
our titration curve is equivalence point
one at equivalence point one all of the
h2a plus has been converted into h a
so now we have one mole of h a present
next let's think about adding 0.5 moles
of hydroxide anions so that would only
neutralize half of the h2a plus that was
initially present
therefore if we go to 0.5 moles of
hydroxide anions and we go up to where
that intersects our titration curve this
point represents the half equivalence
point or half equivalence point one for
this titration
next let's look at half equivalence
point one in more detail so here is half
equivalence point one on the titration
curve so if we started out with one mole
of h2a plus and we've added 0.5 moles of
hydroxide anions we've neutralized half
or 0.5 moles of the h2a plus therefore
at the half equivalence point we have
half a mole of h2a plus and half a mole
of h a which means the concentration of
h2a plus is equal to the concentration
of ha and because at this point we have
significant amounts of both the weak
acid and its conjugate base we formed a
buffer so notice how the ph changes very
slowly in this region around the half
equivalence point one so this is called
buffer region 1 right in here and since
we've formed a buffer the
henderson-hasselbalch equation tells us
when the concentration of the weak acid
is equal to the concentration of the
conjugate base the ph of the solution is
equal to the pka
of the weak acid in this case we're
talking about the pka value of the more
acidic proton so the proton that's on
the oxygen in h2a plus
so if we find the half equivalence point
and we go over to where this intersects
with the y-axis
the ph at this point should be equal to
the pka value for the more acidic proton
so looking at the y-axis here it looks
like it's a little bit over two and in
reality the value of pka1 is equal to
2.34
next let's go back to the first
equivalence point which occurred after
we added one mole of hydroxide anions so
at this point we have h a
if we think about adding another mole of
hydroxide anions so going from one mole
total to two moles total the extra mole
of hydroxide anions will completely
neutralize the h a and turn it into a
minus
so one mole of h a reacts with one mole
of hydroxide anions to form one mole of
a minus
and since the extra mole of hydroxide
anions completely neutralized the h a
and turned into a minus after we've
added a total of two moles of hydroxide
anions we go up to where that intersects
our titration curve and this point
represents equivalence point two so the
equivalence point one occurs after
adding one mole of hydroxide anions and
we can see the ph by going over to the y
axis and equivalence point two occurs
after we've added a total of two moles
of hydroxide anions
let's go back to our first equivalence
point where we had one mole of h a
and at that point we've already added
one mole of hydroxide anions and so if
we add another 0.5 moles of hydroxide
anions to give a total of 1.5 moles we
would neutralize half of the h a
and turn half of it into a minus
therefore we have another half
equivalence point after 1.5 moles of
hydroxide anions have been added
let's look in more detail at half
equivalence 0.2 which is right here on
our titration curve after we've added
1.5 moles of hydroxide anions
since we've neutralized half of the ha
that was present at equivalence point
one now the concentration of h a is
equal to the concentration of a minus
and since we have significant amounts of
both the weak acid and its conjugate
base we have a buffer present in the
region around half equivalence point two
so we can see the ph is changing very
slowly in this region around the half
equivalence point as hydroxide anions
are added and so this represents buffer
region two and because the concentration
of weak acid is equal to the
concentration of its conjugate base the
henderson-hasselbalch equation tells us
the ph at this point is equal to the pka
value in this case it would be pka2 so
one of the acidic protons on the
nitrogen so we can find the value for
pka2 by locating half equivalence 0.2
and going over to
see where that intersects with our
y-axis it looks to be a little bit under
10 which matches with the actual pka2
value which turns out to be 9.87
finally let's go back to the two
equivalence points for our titration
curve the number of equivalence points
in a titration curve for a polyprotic
acid is equal to the number of acidic
protons in the acid therefore since we
titrated a diprotic acid with two acidic
protons the titration curve has two
equivalence points